- On this episode, we go to floor 12,
have a hardcore Eagles fan,
and I get a little Dear Abby-ish.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 143
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm on floor 12.
Woke up some people.
I know the Eagles thing
is comin' from Price,
and then that's comin' this whole episode.
I'm actually pissed I sat in front of him.
Look for my official
Jets Eagles prediction.
By the way, India, I am two and oh
on my official predictions on this season.
So, I'll be coming Friday.
I mean, at some level,
some of you are gonna
start betting heavily
on my skill set here.
I really understand this Jets team.
Good mood.
Excited to be on 12.
DRock, stand, you can stand up
and give 'em a little 12 action.
Love floor 12.
Floor 12 is loud, just the way I like it.
Alright, that's about it.
Super excited about the
comments on the street.
I will be doing more of that.
I almost did that, but I
decided to go with 12 today
and mix it up a little bit
here as we are now getting
to the mid 150s area, which
is a pretty epic feat.
Appreciate all the statement of the days.
You might have noticed I'm
engaging more on YouTube.
Finally put the app on the
front of my home screen,
and have stayed in, consistently signed in
and have figured out my
cadence on engaging on YouTube
which excites me 'cause so
many of you consume the show
on the Tube, and so I
will be not just reading,
but engaging a little bit more there,
so Facebook and that.
Also, a lot of you may not realize this.
I am constantly on in
a Twitter environment,
and so for a lot of you that either
don't have a Twitter account
or are not using it as often,
feel free to ping me there.
A lot of engagement with
the Vayner Nation there.
So India, let's get into the show.
- (laughs) OK.
- Yeah, DRock, you were slow.
DRock was slow.
- [Voiceover] Clinton asks,
"Were you ever reckless
"with any of your businesses?"
- No, I don't think
I've ever been reckless
with my businesses, hence
why they've been successful.
I think the only reckless
thing I've ever done
which has caused me
non-successful ventures
is trying to bite off
more than I can chew.
Sometimes I'm doing way too many things
including now, including always.
So there's a level of
recklessness within it,
but on an overall collective,
it's not reckless because
it's a net net score game
and I win in business.
And so no, I don't find
myself to be super reckless.
I think I'm very much on the offense,
but there's a level of practicality.
I'm very P and L driven, profit and loss.
That means cash flow,
understanding how not to
put myself out of business.
I think I leave a lot of
profit on the table each year.
I definitely could have a
lot more take home money
from Vayner Media, for example,
in the last three years,
but I continue to invest in my businesses.
Some may think that's, not reckless,
but maybe leaving something on the table?
I look at it as long-term investing,
not worrying about short-term cash.
So no, I don't think I'm
a reckless businessman.
That's it.
No.
- [India] Alright, Trouty sent me a link--
- Trouty?
We put Trouty on this show?
- [India] Yeah.
- Jesus.
- [India] The Kardashians
are starting their own web--
- Jesus, Trouty. OK.
- [India] He wants to know...
- [Voiceover] Trouty
asks, "First Glenn Beck,
"and now Kim Kardashian?
"Are subscription media
sites next celeb frontier?
"And will you?"
- The answer is yes.
Will I have one?
I, maybe, ya know?
Maybe, I mean, that's a
really interesting question.
I'd be really fascinated,
and I know Staphon's holding
up the Scope right now.
I'd be really fascinated
if I decided to paywall
The #AskGaryVee Show or my
content, what would happen.
My intuition is that I would
lose 90% of my audience,
but the 10% that were the most passionate
would find a rationale to pay for it.
I do believe paywalls
are an intriguing play.
If you look at somebody like Howard Stern.
Went to a radio paywall.
I think, until he went back
out into America's Got Talent,
he almost disappeared off
the face of the earth.
He made a lot of money,
but his brand took a hit.
For example, I'm gonna
assume a lot of you,
and a lot of you, which
are both one in the same,
are gonna buy a lot of #AskGaryVee books
or go to some of my speeches
where this is a jab.
The content is free, but it's
a gateway to brand equity
that then kind of allows me
to monetize on the back end.
I do think that there's a huge opportunity
for paywall subscription based.
I think there's a lot of money in it.
I do think a lot of people
are gonna go that route.
I think you're gonna see moves by YouTube,
I think as we have a long
tail of micro-celebrity,
more people will go there.
And so, Trouty, I do think
there's a frontier in that.
It is something I debate doing.
I tend to believe more in the fact that
I'm not a Beck or a Kardashian,
so I don't have as much equity.
I think at super scale, when
you have broad awareness,
you have a better chance
of having meaningful scale
and who will pay.
I think there's more upside
in me continuing to provide
disproportionate value on this show
and my engagement to keep
building up that equity.
I'm looking for that depth.
I don't have that level of width.
But yeah, I think it's a
very good business model,
and I do think that people will pay.
I do think eight, ten,
twelve, twenty dollars a month
for getting what you really want
is not out of the question
if you have a lot of affinity
for any content,
sports, individuals, and
definitely celebrities.
And so, yes and maybe.
Staphon, what were they saying
on the Scope about that?
- Somebody said, "Paywalls suck
"if you put everything into it."
Other people said that they
would leave in the show.
They don't wanna watch now
'cause they wanna watch the show--
- [Gary] They're literally
leaving the Scope.
- Yeah, some people.
- [Gary] 'Cause they wanna watch it later.
I love that.
- [India] From Bill via e-mail.
- Bill via e-mail.
- [India] Yeah.
- Oh, we're taking e-mail questions now?
I don't think we should open
that can of worms, India.
- [India] But you forwarded this to me.
- Well, I forwarded it to you,
so I guess that's my fault.
OK, understood.
OK, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Bill says, "My
girlfriend of four years and I
"just broke up, and I'm
feeling really depressed.
"For the last four years,
I've had someone to talk to
"about literally everything in
my life, and now that's gone.
"It's hard to believe that
a four year relationship
"ended in 20 minutes.
"I was saving and planning
on proposing to her
"in the next few months, and
now that's not gonna happen.
"I feel empty, I feel
a void, I feel blank.
"Got any advice on how
"to pick the pieces of my life back up?"
- Jesus. (laughs)
You couldn't have warned
me this was coming?
Well, ya know, I mean,
if this was my buddy,
the first thing I would
desperately try to do is
I always feel like the
quickest cure for heartbreak
off a long-term relationship
is a scummy move
of hooking up with as
many girls as possible.
I think it helps in a weird way.
I really do. I think,
I really do think it helps.
So I think, there's only
meaningful relationships
and then kind of like the
vanity of relationships
when you break this down,
and so he's coming from a meaningful place
and I think the vanity of it all,
like the one, the one
micropositive that guys cliche
will think about in this moment is,
"Well, I can hook up with chicks,"
and I think you have to go all in on that.
That will last for about three
weeks to three months of fun
and is a softener.
I think you need to recognize
that you got off easy.
I don't know if it's Bronx Tale
or one of those gangster movies
where the guy owes the kid,
the kid owes the kid 20 bucks,
and he goes and chases him,
and then the gangster grabs him
and goes, "You got off easy.
"You found out he was a
scum bucket for 20 bucks."
You know, brother, I
gotta be honest with you.
I think you got off easy.
I mean, it's a hell of a lot
better that you didn't propose,
that she was, I give her credit.
She, a lot of people, a lot of people
mail it in and get married to
people that they ultimately
aren't fully 100% infatuated,
in love, and for full life,
and I think people are mailing in.
Now that divorce is so easy,
I think that people just kinda do it,
and I actually think, in a
weird way, you got lucky,
and I actually give her a lot of credit
that she, after a four and
a half year relationship,
had the backbone and the guts
to go through a tough process
I'm sure for her as well.
And so I actually think you
look at this as a positive.
I'm an optimist.
It's easy for me to say,
but I think at some level,
you take a step back
and recognize as much as it hurts now,
it would have been tougher and hurt more
to unwind after marriage or,
what's so difficult for so
many, after having children
which creates such a different dynamic
and becomes extremely difficult.
And so, you know, there's
not much I can say
that's gonna make it
feel a whole lot better.
Maybe just talking it out
and getting the question on the show.
The e-mail was asking
for it to be on the show?
Or are we just taking somebody's random?
Oh it just, it came in, OK.
So, that's it man.
I think, go hook up with some chicks
to ease the pain for a few minutes,
and then take a step back and
recognize it's a positive,
and then try to learn from the experience
and find out the qualities
you really loved in her
and try to replicate them in
the next relationship you have,
and you know, maybe even find the things
that you didn't like as much in her
and try to close the gap
and find somebody you love even more.
- [India] That's so good.
- You like that?
- [India] Yeah.
- Thanks, India.
- [Voiceover] JC asks, "Gary,
is Medium the new Tumblr?
"What happened to Tumblr anyway?"
- Is Medium the new Tumblr?
I think Tumblr is a more
creative outlet visually
whereas Medium, I think,
is more creative outlet
in written form.
Tumblr was bought by Yahoo,
and any time you're bought
by a very big media company,
it's going to slow down its innovation.
They need to integrate
a still very big app.
Go look in the Apple top charts.
It's still well entrenched in the top 100,
top 125.
So I think they're totally different.
I think they're both very
viable communication platforms
that matter in society.
I have the benefit, personally,
of being an investor in both.
Early investor in Tumblr and in Medium.
Big fan of both.
We spent a lot of time, you and I,
jamming in Medium.
So, I don't think it's the new Tumblr.
I think Tumblr's still there.
What happened to Tumblr?
I think it's a different
animal now, and I think,
depending on how you want
to communicate to the world,
for example, I think Tumblr
has been a tremendous
anonymous platform for people
where they don't have to be themselves
and they can have pseudo
names or pseudo context
or hotsaucemaster.tumblr.com
is a place where you don't have
to be necessarily your name
and you can communicate to the world,
and I think that really
works for a lot of teenagers
and a lot of youth.
Medium, people tend to be
themselves on that platform
and has been a gateway for them
to be discovered as great
writers or interesting writers.
So they're different,
and that's my two cents
on those two platforms,
and if you're watching this
show or listening to the show,
and you haven't played with
either platform lately,
I think one of the great
things about this show is
not just listening or
watching or being entertained,
is to take action.
And so let's do a little
homework assignment
for episode, what are we, 143? What?
- [India] Three.
- Yeah, 143.
I challenge you, Vayner Nation,
to go out and post three things on Tumblr,
if you haven't in years,
if you never have,
and to write three articles on Medium
if you haven't in a
while or you never had.
I think that, to me, is the energy
as we get closer to episode
200 that I wanna start doing
which is I want to
create more practitioners
in the amount of people that
are listening and watching
to this show right now that have never
created content for either
platform is stunningly high,
and I want to motivate
you, right this second,
to go out and do it because
you will learn from it
and it will make you stronger and better
and that's something I really
wanna do out of this show.
Not just entertain.
You like that right?
- [India] Yeah.
- That was a good little spin.
I'm on fire here.
- [India] Yeah, it's a good episode.
- Dear Abby, practitioner at scale.
Shit's goin' down.
143!
- [India] Alright, last one.
- Yeah, last one.
- [Voiceover] Noel asks,
"How would you best deal
"with vulturous, unethical investors?
"Would you put 'em on blast?"
- Yeah, I mean, if they're truly
vulturous or unethical investors,
I'm more than willing
to put them on blast,
but something about this question
makes me also wanna say
make sure that is true.
The level of thin skinness
in young, first-time business people,
let me just say this for the record.
The audacity that is running rampant
in startup land,
that you're a 22 to 24
year old entrepreneur
with zero proven record, and
you're going to the world,
and you want them to give
you one million dollars
at a six million dollar
valuation on your idea
pisses me the fuck off,
and so the answer is yes to both.
I would equally put an entrepreneur
that is out of their goddamn mind
that has not contextualized
the insanity of the
marketplace that we live in
as I would as an investor
who is being vulturous
or unethical and doing the wrong thing,
but please recognize sitting
in this ecosystem as I am,
I have had a lot of
kids come to me and say,
"Can you believe this other investor
"that's part of our deal?"
And when I look at it, it is very normal.
I would even say, 10 years
ago, soft negotiating,
but by the thin skinness
of our society right now
feels aggressive to this
23-year-old idea Ricky,
and so I would say absolutely,
I would put them on blast,
but boy would I double check
that I don't look like an
asshole five years from now
for crying about somebody
just business negotiating,
and I didn't like it
because I've been so used to
the world giving me eighth place trophies
and Mom doing my homework
and having no repercussions for anything
for the first 22 years of my life.
Good show.
Feeling pretty good.
12 brought me some.
Would you stop with that bullcrap?
I mean, you guys are oh and two.
Your team's a disaster
- I still love 'em though.
- You should love them, but maybe
maybe you should focus on your work
instead of putting up the football
in the background, yeah.
Yeah, work, work.
I hate Eagle fans this week.
Thanks for watching the show.
Really feelin' it.
Yesterday was a big Jewish holiday,
so I was supposed to be checked out,
but obviously I was catching up
on reading a lot of the
comments, and I appreciate it.
The energy is real,
and I like it.
And so lurkers, this would
be a good time to come out
and say hello.
Floor 12, thank you for your hospitality.
Statements of the day
really mean a lot to me,
so critique the show,
tell me what you think about floor 12,
tell me what you think
about that last answer,
and that's the scoop.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)